now if you Google the manosphere uh the
definition that you're going to get
online is probably something along the
lines of the manosphere is a collection
of websites blogs YouTube channels and
online forums promoting to varying
degrees masculinity dating advice
misogyny and strong opposition to
feminism communities within the
manosphere include men's rights
activists so these are the mras
not very effective but they're out there
trying to do something the in cells
which are the involuntary syllabus these
are the guys that want to be with women
but have absolutely no luck the men that
are going their own way which are very
similar to the in cells but I mean
technically they should have chosen to
go the on way and not be sent their own
way so there's a distinction there that
you have to consider I covered mgtow by
the way in a chapter in my book so I'm
not going to spend a lot of time on that
the pickup artist
I am the father's rights groups so those
would be the main definitions you'll get
if you search for that so
they just say this is the manosphere
okay so they might technically say I'm
in the manosphere because a lot of the
conversations that I have it might
capture Jordan Peterson it might capture
God's side it might capture Andrew Tate
um you know by that definition but most
guys will disassociate from it because
it has a very very bad PR
um issue uh anytime there's a shooting
somebody like a school shooting somebody
rents a van and drives over a bunch of
people like that nerd did in Toronto
they'll immediately blame the manosphere
okay
um and you'll notice in this definition
you'll find online they use the word
misogyny which is a very strong word I
don't think the manosphere is for the
most part misogynist you'll probably
find some misogynist in there but
generally speaking I wouldn't say as a
whole the manosphere is misogynist I
think that most sorry not most I would
say there's a good number of of guys in
the manosphere that are genuinely
uh on point
are speaking from a good position of
authority and you should probably have a
have a listen to them and I'll talk
about some of the YouTube channels in a
little bit but that's a definition let
me keep scrolling down here on some of
the notes so I've got a chapter in my
follow-up book I'm gonna I'm gonna get
into detail it's about
[ __ ] it's 14 pages long right now so
um maybe I'll Whittle this down or I
don't know maybe I'll even add to it but
it's but it's a little bit of a a guide
from the perspective as
of a writer I'm not going to cover
everything in this video
so here's a few of the problems one of
the things I was talking about when
creating this video is I wanted to get
into a lot of the issues with the metal
swamp and one of them is the drama redmi
component
um it is prolific in this space I've
dealt with a bunch of different
Industries credit card debt relief
collections entrepreneurs uh
young entrepreneurs startup groups I've
I spent a lot more time in
entrepreneur's org than I did in the man
of swamp if I'm being honest and it was
a group of mostly guys there were some
gals in it who were also very effective
and productive as well but good friends
would never slander each other publicly
anywhere they were often
you know getting together for Christmas
parties introducing each other family
sort of thing they'd have a pool party
in the summer your kids would be running
around very comfortable environment
they're the kind of people that you'd
want to have over to dinner you know
with your kids sitting at the table and
you feel comfortable them being there I
can't say the same for a lot of the man
of swamp characters right
um
so
with EO moving into the Mana swamp I saw
something that was really completely
different
and it didn't hit me very quickly but it
but it hit me it hit me
um you know you would see guys
fight over the most trivial things and
then they would use their platform to
manufacture drama between Their audience
and then the other creators audience in
some cases there have been guys in the
manosphere that have had to take
security measures to protect their
family from the Rabid lunatics that some
of the other creators would mobilize
um it's not a very collaborative space
and even if it does collaborate it
doesn't seem to do so for a very long
period of time in the time that I was
there I did
almost three speaking gigs at a live
conference I definitely did two and I
was lined up for a third uh I walked
away from that because that was turning
into serious problems I collaborated on
a panel show twice two different panel
shows both of which I also founded and
had to leave them both as well so
I mean like even internally when you
work with people there's still problems
um it's not a productive space like I
said it's got not only does it have a PR
issue but it has an internal issue with
collaborating bickering infighting straw
mining ad-hom attacks doxing underhanded
childish behavior is actually very
common some of you have probably seen it
some of you will see it if you're newer
to the space but it is going to come
your way and if it has come your way and
you're still around I'm going to say
this you're stupid for sticking around
okay
it's not a place that you need to
subscribe to you don't have diabetes you
don't have to stick around and have them
keep selling sending you medicine every
since of a month okay I know big Pharma
wants you on that model they want your
health on their plan and there's maybe
some degree where there's some creators
in a Mana swamp that wants your love
life or your personal life hooked into
their uh dopamine hits you know for
example
you can learn what you need to learn and
you can leave okay the Mana swamps like
training wheels on a bicycle for you to
learn Basics around attraction arousal
what women really respond to how to
maintain frame how to keep the gals
around
um you know all of those elements a lot
of the stuff I've talked about in a book
a lot of stuff I've talked about in my
prior videos on this channel my other
channels I've covered a lot I've been
doing this since 20
16 or 17 I mean I started the channel in
2014 and it was about two years in so
maybe 2016 that I started having these
conversations and then that's when they
suck me in right I had about
maybe 80 to 100 000 Subs that's when the
manosphere came for me like I didn't
look for it it just said hey we have the
speaking event hey let's collab on this
sort of thing and I was happy to do it
because I wanted to help I wanted guys
to get the same Clarity that I did I'm a
problem-solving creature I've always
told guys that follow me for
entrepreneur's advice one of the most
important skills you need to develop is
your problem-solving muscle so I wanted
to solve problems for myself and I saw
it as hey there's some good resources
here so let's amplify them there was a
lot of guys that were just a
non-bloggers or maybe just on Twitter
um using a pen name and I I would
amplify them I would say hey you know
I've read your book or I like this about
something that I've read from you on
your blog so let's so let's amplify that
on you know my Channel that I introduce
into my audience and a lot of those guys
are you know producing now as a result
of that
so
that's what I stepped into a lot of a
lot of people that uh
you know are very interesting characters
like I said bickering and fighting straw
Manning very common people that befriend
you betray you uh is very disloyal and
arrogant and stupid it's you know it's a
lot of things uh we talked about
amplifying drama
I think I talked about why I played in
the sandbox so I can kind of skip over
that
uh I'll tell you why these groups stay
underground
they never really go mainstream one of
the questions that I was always asked
for quite a few years was how do we get
this mainstream how do we get this to mo
more guys and the problem is is you're
never going to get it to more guys
because most guys they don't want to
hear this they just don't it's it's as
soon as you like you know if if a guy's
having a problem with his girlfriend and
maybe her eyes are starting to wander
and then you just come up to me and go
well you know Bob women don't care about
your struggles they hang out at the
finish line and they pick the winner and
here's a video from Rich Cooper you
should check this out they'll just look
at you like you've got you know four
eyeballs across your forehead and an
antler sticking out that way they just
don't understand they're not ready for
it they're only ready to receive these
messages when chaos has hit their life
and that's and that's how they usually
find it it's unfortunate that that's the
way that guys operate
but it is what it is
that's how guys you know solve these
problems
so it stays Fringe because it can't
organize agree and collaborate in a
productive manner
it's like a bus with about 80 seats on
it and every member of the bus is trying
to be in the driver's seat and
constantly fighting over every little
detail
oh why don't you debate me on this set
or the other thing it's one of my other
favorites too let's have a debate
they focus on descriptions for the most
part but fail to provide Solutions or
prescriptions which is what I've always
been doing
um I won't have a conversation on a
topic without offering you guys valuable
solutions to that problem I'm a
Solutions guy like I'll identify the
problem
educate myself on it learn how the rules
work and then I'll offer a solution to
it just how I roll
okay but the difference is that
the whole
space knows that red meat sells right if
you can if you can produce a good amount
of red meat and get eyeballs with your
thumbnails titles and tags
you've got views it's I'm going to tell
you guys straight up you want to create
a YouTube channel and uh create drama
between creators or even create like a
news channel I'm sure there's an
opportunity out there to create a mantle
swap news channel manoswamp daily you
know you can call it and then you can
break down all the drama that happens
between all the creators because I I bet
you'd get eyeballs on that people would
watch that because people like drama
they like the car accident everybody
looks at the stupid car accident even
when it's off the road they just love
that [ __ ] I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out